picture what's happening now were you
mother [ __ ] are the priests you
understand what's going on Lisa yeah you
got me all fired up this morning like I
am [ __ ] around I was telling Li of my
Jewish people is you [ __ ] kids true
cuz all this racism [ __ ] ain't nobody
races here my scene life for what the
[ __ ] it is okay when I see a Jew yeah
okay like when I see these clothes Jew
that they're walking on timid like
walking looking at the floor they make
an eye contact with nobody and I see a
Jew a yeah I know it you out here is
walking around thinking about what a
beautiful day it is to be alive and you
in New York
yeah when they get up in the morning I
got that has city capital it's like
Zorro
you don't think I'm dabbing a
[ __ ] how they gonna take some of
these pennies today cuz they know
pennies turn into dollars and dollars
turns and I was telling Lee the strength
of the strength of the [ __ ] Jewish
person in this country why you know
listen man
every nationalities in this country is
suffered the blacks got brought from
Africa to a place they didn't know the
Cubans the Jews did jerk everybody's
[ __ ] suffered here let me tell you
something it comes from the Jews you
think of their strength you think
where's your strength come from as a
human being it comes from what you went
through and what you get over you know
when those Jews were in that [ __ ]
basement with no air conditioning on
with [ __ ] tattoos on their arms with
no head and saw their friends dying tell
me that for them didn't get together and
say when we get out of this [ __ ]
it's gonna be a different world we're
gonna teach our children that never
again are they gonna get [ __ ] in the
ass like we did this is never gonna
happen again you tell me you tell me
that that attitude those we've only
discussed this I think he went re me and
how he discusses the sons of the whole
across people mhm there were toughest
[ __ ] him they were tough as nails
probably yes the anger in their hearts
was transferred you know what had
happened to them don't tell me that that
that I cuz that's what you wake up
worried morning you wake up you think of
those [ __ ] numbers that they put on my
grandfather's honor I gotta go out there
clay stabbed my mother [ __ ] cuz my you
know I'm mad cuz some guy is making me
move because he dented my car
taking what you grandfather woke up with
in the mornings with those tattoos and
he saw those numbers on his wrists and
those people yelling at him so they got
strength from somewhere you get your
strength from brother is your [ __ ]
culture sometimes like me I know my
mother stabbed somebody for rape and her
little sister makes me [ __ ] a savage
that's why she had an alias
that's why my mother had an alias will
you get your strike I don't know what
the [ __ ] I'm talking about it but I know
it's going to be an interesting podcast
cause legally I was talking about this
sterling [ __ ] but anyway let's open up
with some beautiful [ __ ] minutes a
beautiful day to be alive I had a great
time in Baltimore what a great [ __ ]
City I'm not thinking of lack people
black people running [ __ ] Baltimore
Donald sterling would be dead by now if
he made a from Baltimore they don't [ __ ]
around him both man they really don't
then that it's a really interesting city
I was telling ro going on the ride to
the thing that when I first got into
comedy
there was only two clubs that gave me
love and it was the club Joey's in
Detroit and this club in Baltimore I was
just a beat [ __ ] hole and it was like
beat up black people and beat up white
people it was the refuge of the city
that nobody wanted and this guy would
put me up man two weeks a month you know
on the weekend and put me in a whole
town and I wasn't good at all
you know I wasn't good I was a little
dirty and I was from New York so he
liked me upfront but he gave me a lot of
work but I remember what Baltimore look
like it looked like a bomb [ __ ] I hit
it and now it's it's beautiful
look the downtown was [ __ ] beautiful
it really is it really really [ __ ] is
beautiful I had a nice time the people a
[ __ ] show you know it was 2,000
people and after we got out there and
the line was from here the [ __ ]
wanker is and we took pictures number
after till midnight and it's just very
nice to be a part of something as a
comedian you know Lee was saying that
the he saw the commercial for David
Spade last night
and I was telling to leave that you know
listen guys I'm not the best [ __ ]
comic out there but the last six weeks
on the road I've learned a lot about
myself you know for a lot of Dale in
Boston and New Jersey and the people
that came to Grand Rapids you know guys
I I feel like I'm on to something now
stand-up wise especially I paid my dues
and you know I was telling Lee as a Jew
as a bad ass business Jew as a business
and there's not one Jew with Comedy
Central looks at the oven girls come
here for a second ideas guy everything
like he's a [ __ ] fat slob oh no the
[ __ ] they want to say but this
[ __ ] on for something why don't
we give him a little something just in
case
well you'll undo a special if it goes
well it goes well if it doesn't we write
it off and say he's a bum but at least
we have him in our [ __ ] catalog you
know that's business sometimes you let
your feelings get ahead of what you
really are I appreciate it
that they don't want to do it but David
Spade like I've said a thousand times
loved the guy loved his TV shows B
hasn't said nothing that somebody hasn't
written from funny in [ __ ] 30 [ __ ]
years and I'm not lying even nobody I'm
not playing eight know whatever there's
a lot of people way [ __ ] funny on TV
anyway what the [ __ ] are we going play
with this [ __ ] how come you're not
[ __ ] control in the podcast what's up
baby would you do all weekend cuz I look
at apartments I had the most I called
you and I wish you were there like thank
you for making me walk just if I never
if I'd died tomorrow that I was the
happiest I ever was on Saturday so
where'd you go okay so I was I went to
go look at an apartment and I had time
in between another one so I wasn't got
some lunch and I just had to walk to the
next apartment was like half a mile away
so I was walking and there were like a
lot of homeless people and I figured out
why it's cuz the grocery store nearby
had a can delivery place so they all
they all hang out there this woman was
walking towards me she looked me
straight in the face she said did I see
you yesterday I said no she said do you
walk on the Brea and that's in Hollywood
and I live in the valley so I'm like no
she's like let me ask you something
I hear Warner Brothers is paying people
to walk around and pretend they're
Jewish I think what do you think about
that I'm like no she's like I think
that's true I hear they don't really do
anything they pretend they're Jewish
I said maybe and I walked away laughing
for about 15 minutes you did not know
you were the find you she didn't know
any no not and the funniest thing is
most people get to not with now a
distant my name's a find you but in life
people usually like are surprised when I
say I'm Jewish I don't know why that a
parent
I don't look like a Jew I don't know
what any either anyway you got my snows
but just the fact that she said I hear
Warner Brothers into paying people to
pretend they're Jewish it made me laugh
for about 15 it never runs it never ends
no I told you that I had tracked the
funniest people sometimes when you wind
up in this world life gives you material
and if you sat down on stage because of
the conversations we have here nobody
would believe it really yeah because
come on he calls you to find you and
some homeless lady comes up to you and
says are they paying people to act quite
Jews in Hollywood think about that
that's hysterical now you don't know
live the life comedian where you see
life you know it just flows [ __ ]
apples at you sometimes like something
happens it's hysterical
like I'm here by myself like the time I
was in Florida a couple weeks ago there
ain't no [ __ ] Americas yeah but when
you're a comic and you have that mind
sometimes the universe throws certain
things that you if I have had things
happen to me when I'm alone that that's
when I wish I had to blog he but the
blog II wouldn't accord it right because
I wasn't thinking that way it's like
when people show you videos of a the
other day John Ramos showed me a video
of a [ __ ] leopard attacking an
alligator that [ __ ] probably I was
invited back to leopard swims real low
and he comes out you fail yourself who
had the camera yeah who had the [ __ ]
camera they're like that's brilliantly
that's the first thing I think about was
that guy standing there they leave it
there overnight you know I mean what
we're gonna have to get you I don't know
I don't think it has this capability but
you know having none of those Google
glasses that they came out with you we
have to get you those what's wrong with
glasses you see what the [ __ ] supporting
all the time it's amazing and I talk
about this constantly people and I love
you guys and part of this podcast it was
supposed to be really [ __ ] funny I'm
a comedian but turns into different
things I see [ __ ] when I'm out that
amazes the [ __ ] out of me you know what
the iPhone is made for to detract us I
mean it is amazing that people get shot
in public places airports and I see
people never paying attention well it's
the worst at the airport people you're
not paying attention to life man you're
in that thing through [ __ ] much when
I sit down at a dinner table or
something after I look around after I
got my seat facing the [ __ ] door
because I'm watching everything that's
going on then I bring that [ __ ] phone
but until that time I can't tolerate
people looking at that [ __ ] phone
when life is going on around them man
that's why I don't put all that [ __ ] on
my [ __ ] phone because I don't want to
look at that right now I'll look at it
later it's got nothing to do with me
right now if somebody not you know it's
the weirdest [ __ ] thing what the
phone does to people and with all the
bad [ __ ] that happens how people do not
pay [ __ ] attention to life is beyond
me well you see people in the cities
when people actually have to walk people
walking in the sack do stuff because
they walk with it and you see the video
I think was in Chicago of the people on
the bus and some guy took out a gun and
no one noticed he just got on the bus
because no one noticed he was all pissed
off he's like freeze and I was like [ __ ]
yeah he just said [ __ ] nobody's
paying attention got me on yes it's it's
I see that the park might take my
daughter okay I took my daughter to the
park I really [ __ ] see how people act
like they're on the phone you can't
listen man when it comes to a kid it's a
split second what do people always say I
took my eye off him for one minute all
that one [ __ ] minute this times I
turn around I look back and she's on top
of [ __ ] out of it oh god she's
halfway standing around and her foot is
an inch away from the end and I'm
looking at this going on she's just
happy she's balancing herself she takes
one step she's going down head [ __ ]
first yeah I see it on the seesaw she
gets on the seesaw sometime but I see it
with parents and you know what I could
see when you're single and you're
walking around you look like that
[ __ ] [ __ ] phone when you got a
[ __ ] kid and [ __ ] you've got to pay
attention you have to pay it
amantha life I'm telling you right now
it's the weirdest thing the idea was on
Koufax making a left to go to the coffee
shop from [ __ ] Chandler okay you know
you wait they're all [ __ ] day for a
green light to that left yeah that's you
that's the ride away well as I'm
shooting some chick I swear to god cuts
in front of me and I look and I pull the
[ __ ] car next to her and I look at
her and she's on the thing like driving
hitting about to hit the sidewalk and I
beat and she looks up and I go what the
[ __ ] you don't know she does she gives
me two fingers rides away because god
forbid she said I'm sorry yeah that's a
bid that miserable [ __ ] took the time
she was so indulged in whatever the [ __ ]
was that quit with her [ __ ] rental
ain't Range Rover and that [ __ ]
miserable [ __ ] [ __ ] could I'm sorry
about the language but his Monday
morning we gotta drop it
yeah I'm saying [ __ ] it nothing good
happens unless you tell the truth on a
[ __ ] Monday this dummy [ __ ] you
know was looking at the text and she
looked at me and she you know and then
she doesn't claim responsibility I know
except an item to say I'm [ __ ] sorry
right you know it's just the end of this
[ __ ] well I read an article that was
Tara I don't I don't remember the city
was in but two years ago these three 16
year old kids were riding their bike and
this this mom was driving a minivan and
in hit the kids that were driving hit
the kids biking one of them tied one of
them ended up in the hospital and two
years later the mom is suing the kids
family who died because the fact that
she killed him is causing her mental
things that she's saying he they weren't
biking I looked for the rules of the
road
and like the kids family is like
freaking out like they're like how could
you how could you do this to us two
years later people are I mean and then
like last week or something there's this
big article that this this uh this
little teenage girl hit someone biking
and said oh I don't really care I was
just one of those rich girls and people
are it's driving is [ __ ] scary now I
don't [ __ ] I only comes to driving at
petrifies the [ __ ] out of me mm-hmm I
Drive on the offensive with my foot on
that [ __ ] gas which means if you [ __ ]
around me I'll clock your [ __ ] car I
don't give a [ __ ] about Geico
George come please I Drive on the
[ __ ] offensive man and on the
defensive Bobby offensive I Drive on the
offensive defensive that's a new [ __ ]
defense I put together there well yeah
I mean you have to go you have to drive
on the offensive defense that's right
that's right I'll [ __ ] you hit this
point I've never touch it [ __ ] and
you know what the worst thing is I'm
pretty sure he's scraping the inside of
my door now cuz I take pictures every
day and there's more marks now so he's
[ __ ] he's doing something so this is
so what's going on with Donald [ __ ]
Sparrow
well I mean I the funniest thing about
this is everyone talking about this as
or why people but uh so first of all
before I say anything he's a he's a
terrible racist look he's a bad everyone
and he's no they've said it for years
that he's just like he he's had to pay
people off for doing this like his old
employees and the people who who live in
his apartment buildings every everyone's
known for years and he's a racist this
isn't like the first time so he everyone
knows he's a racist he said that he said
some pretty offensive things about black
people but when you think about it
I'll old white people and their home by
themself are gonna say some pretty
offensive things this if I were a
millionaire or a billionaire like an old
man I would listen to this and I would
never get a 20 year old again because
this woman secretly recorded him I don't
know how many times if you listen to the
tape she provoked him she knew exactly
what it'd be like I came to you and said
what do you think about these the Hindus
working at 7-eleven and recorded you I
know what you're gonna say and then she
stole two million dollars from him so I
mean he said some pretty terrible things
but what do you everyone's a terrible
things at home so I mean I'm just you
know I'm happy that you
when you think about this yes something
nothing kills me the most when people
act surprised yeah like people like oh
my god I can't believe it's 2014 that
somebody would think this way I say a
lot of crazy show on his show but
everybody knows that you know I wouldn't
have anything if it wasn't for black
people and I came from Cuba they're my
best friends and they they they gave me
the gift of friendship I never [ __ ]
forgot that and the posters on my wall
Richard Pryor and Julius Erving and you
know Denzel Washington's my favorite I
mean you know when you talk sometimes
you talk out of content you talk to be
funny but everybody knows deep down
inside you know my go-to acupuncture
I've been infatuated with the Chinese
Way of life and before because of my
mother my mother was a big Chinatown
chick she would go to Chinatown when I
was a kid and buy different herbs and
drink them for different ailments and I
sold it did her she used to have this
thing for my Latina it's this little
[ __ ] yellow thing of a container it
smells weird you put this on any elbow
or muscle or a knee and I believe in
that [ __ ] I just lazy go down and do it
my first girlfriend was [ __ ] Chinese
Irish there hasn't been a woman that's
Irish - if you're Irish you're a woman
you got dirty feet you better [ __ ] be
careful cuz I'm all over you Jewish well
my best friend G when are you [ __ ]
Shaffir so do you understand me people
I've always well I'm from in North
Bergen New Jersey it's a beautiful place
you guys hear me say beautiful things
about North Bergen but they're racist
[ __ ] and I've always told other
Spanish people I lived there are Cuban
kids I've said listen man this is not
fair that's great but always remember at
the end of the day you're always a
[ __ ] speck and as long as you know
that going in it makes your life a lot
easier you know if the guys known to
being racist whatever I don't know what
happened I just read this year Instagram
pictures well I mean how racist could he
be she's black and he's banging it he's
black in Mexican he's eating that
[ __ ] ass he's sucking that day you
know one thing I don't this chick one
thing that you bump into the other day I
went to the airport mm-hmm when I flew
out of here and there was a woman that
was at 12 but I wouldn't want to be 5
feet from her and the guy she was with
was a [ __ ] loser - he was a [ __ ]
[ __ ] -
and this chick was one of these / Asian
black chicks that was tremendously odd
faked a tremendous rack tremendous ass
but she even tried to get attention at
the airport at 6:00 in the [ __ ] walk
like that's what she was doing and she
was talking loud and you know on my
first-class tickets by the window you
know so everybody could [ __ ] him here
and it was just embarrassing for this
chick and you could see that she was
desperate she had no [ __ ] Talent see
this chick Kim Kardashian see 20 years
ago was okay view a woman and you had no
[ __ ] talent this [ __ ] town because
people would do this but now you know
you had none I'm sorry I'm saying if the
wrong [ __ ] way now because it can
Kadesh it now am i mad at it I don't
give a [ __ ] about it it makes no
difference to me you get these chicks
parading around and they always find
some old man to give him two or three
thousand dollars and these chicks walk
around like they're doing something
special in their life yeah but meanwhile
they're sucking at the end of the day
they're sucking some old dick selling
your soul yeah this guy's yeah this guy
looks like Mickey Rourke that the
operation just went bad so here's this
check I still looked at the Instagram
and she's a pig you know she's out there
doing whatever Fanny told you you could
[ __ ] black guys then he said yeah you
could suck that black yak the Ox stick
whatever the [ __ ] you want you could do
whatever the [ __ ] you want just don't
bring him to my [ __ ] thing if you go
to a clipper game it's all black people
yeah
so what the [ __ ] you know it's like now
everybody knows the guy is irate he just
said yourself he's paid out before like
apparently like he's like I forgot the
guy's name but I'm player a couple years
ago said like the he like he it was his
player on the court
his highest-paid player they saying like
he's calling on the n-word and calling
him stupid and he's a [ __ ] it's like
the that [ __ ] cook a few months ago
Paula Deen who who wanted to have slaves
and her brother's wedding you know what
it's it's it's a terrible thing and you
hope racism isn't there and I think with
each generation we're getting a little
bit less racist but maybe but it's
always there but probably were funny
listen it's always there it's all you
have to assume it's [ __ ] there and
I'm not gonna sit here and play the
racist stick that I have no
opportunities you make your own [ __ ]
dummies in this life you'll never hear
me say that
this is not because I'm CUBAN [ __ ]
I've got on after it like a [ __ ] Jew
and heat you understand me and if you're
not going after it like that then you
then those are the people that throw
race - oh my god I'm racist I don't hire
braces people keep that [ __ ] if you're
the best of what you do when you go in
there balls out they don't give a [ __ ]
what color if I know you can man from
corporation you know you can make them
eighty [ __ ] million dollars how he
knows you don't give a [ __ ] what color
they are the only color he concerned
about is [ __ ] green there's a
difference between being racist I can't
be racist
I could pork [ __ ] because I'm trying to
be funny I'm a [ __ ] [ __ ] when I can
never in my heart be racist I could
never never never in my heart because I
know what these races have done for me
when I got out of the [ __ ] prison who
tweeted me who tooted me and gaming on
an education on economics I never knew
about Mohammed is a beep Muhammad's a
beep was his name Muhammad to be with
sandals on I used to laugh at this guy
this guy's to break bread with me in my
house I used to break bread with him at
his house and every humus you know
wasn't popular that you know I'm saying
it wasn't cool for [ __ ] Arab gotta
bust out hummus people say put that away
it's love it but the understand me so
all the [ __ ] I talk is [ __ ] but you
know what's coming you know my heart is
there's people just genuinely don't give
a [ __ ] and most people all those people
I tell you what I didn't like though
like I looked at Snoop Dogg stack Snoop
Dogg was like hey to the president of
the Lakers oh [ __ ] you you chicken
eating [ __ ]
then you fight racism of racism because
I know when ten black guys are together
they say look at that [ __ ] pencil
neck whatever they call chicken neck
whatever yeah and white [ __ ] and
I don't get mad at that I don't get that
hey Dawg that's what this is that's what
the media wants that's what they want
they want that little anger in you that
20% anger they want you to walk around
they're always trying to create this
[ __ ] thing you don't hear about that
the doctor who saved the blind kid but
you always hear about the cop who who
sent the racist statement in Oklahoma
they always come up with the [ __ ]
video over him hit the [ __ ] black guy
you know they want that tension there I
don't want that tension there
my life and something yeah dad I pulled
up to a black guy and so he had a
Cadillac and I pulled up next to him and
I said something like yo what's
happening baby boy and he looked at me
was another planet and I said how's the
Cadillac run how is this a new top 2014
and we started talking you know you
always notice that when you're around
black people you sound a little blacker
oh you know like a lot of people do hey
brother you always throw like a slang or
something to have them you know why am i
left there I was like what the [ __ ] is
wrong with me
yeah and that's the most important thing
when I watch 12 years of slave a couple
weeks ago on that place the first 45
minutes I couldn't ask myself what a
[ __ ] my watching this was it bad well
this isn't what I believe in this is not
my belief this is not even my [ __ ]
world
I couldn't exist in those world those
times I couldn't exist that was not that
those centuries were not made for me I
couldn't do that to another human being
but that's just [ __ ] me yeah you know
and then I watch it and I remember it's
a movie and it's a story and I try to
digest it you know when I watched
Amistad and they were throwing the black
people off the [ __ ] [ __ ] you know
they were doing the same thing the
Cubans in 79 who weren't paying they
were taking humans and going you you you
know we called Lisa at he said is gonna
pay you 20 grand but we called them back
one additional 20 grand and you go
[ __ ] they throw you off the [ __ ]
boat and you gonna see his try to
develop that story now but what happens
when the country opens up that the day
that it's beautiful you read about all
the great stories about the guy who came
with all his children and open up a
restaurant they became a millionaire
went back and got his kids but you don't
hear about the people I got thrown off
the [ __ ] boat okay you know from all
over this [ __ ] world we think the
Cubans were the only ones blacks got
thrown off [ __ ] boats out there
listen man every race [ __ ] suffered
and when you make a statement like that
I've said it a thousand times its way
you're [ __ ] artists last weekend on
the podcast I said chanting [ __ ] one
[ __ ] podcast I didn't feel bad about
it at all because I know in my heart was
the biggest fan in the world my main man
chung up there and [ __ ] Baltimore
showed up the end I he knows of my heart
is you know I'm saying yeah I love
Chinese people my little Korean people I
couldn't have that hatred in my heart
even if I [ __ ] tried but it bothers
me
people don't know the animal they're
doing business with you gotta know the
animal you're doing business with
because then this will happen always
keep that in mind this [ __ ]
think someone [ __ ] anyway at the
[ __ ] end though that I don't people
think I'm a criminal at the end of the
day what's the difference in prejudice
I'm a felon you don't think there's
people in the comedy business or in real
life you know he he went to prison at
one time that's another word for me
being [ __ ] black felon and black is
the same [ __ ] word mm-hmm so that
that was the only interesting part to me
is because they're saying that the
Clippers the players and the coach
should have the right to be a free agent
at the end of the season what would you
do if let's say the owner of a comedy
club chain I don't want to say me came
out and had a tape like this and said I
hate Cuban people
what do you work at that comedy club I
don't know I don't know because I know
what this is you think these comedy
clubs hire me because they like Joey
Diaz they hire me because the church is
selling tickets and people come to see
me around for 20 years I know what time
is it demantoid time is with me if like
I told that I was in Grand Rapids I was
telling the other comedians mean I get
offstage do you think I'm the type of
guy that goes into other college and say
when I said that joke
did you see the emotional I'll give a
[ __ ] you think my material is any good
I'm just telling you what's in my life
it's not brilliant [ __ ] material and
there's not a comic that actually worked
harder and sits down and writes a
[ __ ] joke for you whatever I try to
do that but I can't but what I'm talking
about is from my heart and the people
feel it's [ __ ] real my point is that
[ __ ] uh you know I'm not the best
comic out there but people know in my
heart is when people come to see me and
I do the cocaine with the cat joke they
like he really gave his cat Co yeah I
was [ __ ] up I gave him a little
[ __ ] blast that I toured you know I
loved the [ __ ] cat I suffer the
filters when I think about faith you
know this morning I woke up I wake up on
Monday why we got miry [ __ ] day the
only one who was up in the house of the
cats yeah I said I was telling you the
other night that I have a little sign
these two girls
we we Evie and Lulu yeah
it's it's amazing how sweet they are
they're super bad sisters and they lost
a brother
Demi junior DJ they lost him he died
right but Subban lived and the two girls
lived and I have other cats and I've
never had three sweeter cats in all my
life I don't know what those cats have
been mined since day one I've had him in
the yard as they were little kitten as
they play with Maxie and Lulu stands up
to a father I'm like he's gonna kill you
Lulu one vase did that cat thing were
that she got it really skinny and hissed
at him he was little she was a little
[ __ ] [ __ ] I love those cats
I saw those cats grew up I'm going on
vacation to Tennessee with my wife for
three days and missing those cats and
worrying about the cats calling home G
was my friend that upstairs an African
kid his wife she was Japanese and I paid
him money to feed those kittens I was so
worried about in those three days
because in the mornings I'd be out
getting a shower and run downstairs and
say DJ DJ would come running around he'd
play with a ball with me and then
Superbad wouldn't talk to me but the two
girls would come close and that little
chubby thing he V that is my life and
when I wake up on Monday mornings when I
wake up any morning I've gotta tell you
man I go to each of them and I pack them
and I give him a hug that's the coffee's
getting ready I feed them I pick up I
tell my wife and I got 10 minutes of
clean up whoo-hoo rip this down off the
couch and always build up the [ __ ]
hairball who [ __ ] you know rip the
paper and a half loop lock the garbage
down like if you eat shrimp and you put
the shells and the garbage every morning
I wake up to five minutes but no matter
how angry I am sometimes Adam like I
don't get angry but the [ __ ] you wake up
to this [ __ ] I pick them all up in the
morning it's like this morning picked up
[ __ ] Fidel and I pick them over so
hearties I get him and I squeeze him and
I kiss on my tongue I love him
and I picked up Lulu and I picked the
baby I was a leave you got a watch
because when you put it down when you
walk away from watch she gets mad that
you're leaving so you gotta walk back
and it's funny because those are the
only two like I came over and you saw I
mean I'm cool as most your cats now
evening Louie look the only two lugs
don't really mess with me know
Mesa's no by Loulou leave you don't
lesson nobody they just they're like her
father they're tough you know this
morning I was I was feeding them I
looked up at Lulu at Harry by the
[ __ ] neck then I broke him Lou stop
it now when Harry went away I pedal you
a good [ __ ] girl it's a way to
control that [ __ ]
but that hugging those cats man I can't
be racist it puts me in the best mood in
the [ __ ] world when I leave that
house you know five thirty and after I
hug them all because I was leaving
Debbie jumped on top of my backpack
really because he wanted love he was
sleeping I was giving out love and I
want the PATA me dropped like for me to
pet my stomach's like that him I got
down I kissed on my tongue I love them
and it's come on I do that good mornings
man my day [ __ ] changes like no
matter what I'm wake up with with bad
thought is in my mind what I went
through over the weekend what I'm
thinking about you know as soon as I do
that in the morning so it's a man to the
coach Don sterling I don't know what the
[ __ ] is in your heart I mean you had
what you said but you got to stay away
from those scandalous [ __ ] [ __ ]
those women are the worst I mean think
of a woman who sells her soul
look I pee every day and I look at my
dick it's the ugliest [ __ ] thing
sometimes you know when you pee when
you're 25 and you pee when you're 50
it's different Pete
I peed that was somebody farted in the
[ __ ] room Danny this thing that comes
out of your pee hole was [ __ ] amazing
when you're 50 your piss smell really
run this oh my god when I was a little
kid I just have to clean my mother's the
bathroom at the bar
okay men's bathroom I was going there
and the pee smells so [ __ ] bad it
smells so [ __ ] bad as a young kid I
going into what the [ __ ] my pee don't
smile like that well guess what now it
smells like that sometimes when it comes
out yellow it's like a fart coming out
of your dick oh oh and that girl sucks
that old dick I'm 51 I can't imagine
what my disgusting dick and my boss
smell like well he's just a terrible
probably his well he's still married to
his wife his wife went to the game
yesterday so if he's a terrible person
this guy is just a ball of [ __ ] bad
karma yes money but it's so funny at
this chick she sold her soul years ago
I sold the soul I looked at of Instagram
pictures of her and her Range Rover and
her cars and her life is bangin
and she probably pulls up at these
places and she had a professional
photographer take these pictures of her
with a bear on and all this [ __ ] we
wanted to be nice to driver the tape at
all no it's like she was like oh but we
love each other and I'm black I'm mixed
and what I can't really I can't live in
less well then it still has races a
minute it's it's overacting but I mean
it doesn't even know what she's saying
she's just no rigueur gling on the
[ __ ] nut on the [ __ ] whatever
that's in the sperm that she drank that
more yeah she's still great Wanda well
there's a gluten free [ __ ] sperm and
these people don't know what the [ __ ]
they're talking about yeah he's he's 75
[ __ ] years old that shit's gluten
free an old man's sperm they'll not get
[ __ ] wig off what the [ __ ] Lee why
are we talking about this [ __ ] who gives
a [ __ ]
where's my man Tony Bennett this morning
it's Monday morning it's a beautiful day
to be alive brush your teeth comb your
hair smile from the mirror let these
[ __ ] know you're dangerous I
wanna be
somebody breaks your heart
what's up police I got you bad
[ __ ] no edible say I'm taking
care okay because Wednesday I'm making
your [ __ ] hair growing from podcast
right live early morning we'll go for
broke it's the last day of month I'm
giving you two days to find them and see
yourself go for what [ __ ] energy I'll
do whatever time this is looking back on
Wednesday it's gonna be very interesting
though thinking they're gonna make him
sell the team just started getting good
he's gonna lose well you know what man
the fix is in they were in the playoffs
he just he just destroyed the whole
playoff oh yeah like that girl just
destroyed the whole playoffs they're
broken they're walking around and they
young so they can't believe what
happened but they should have known you
know you there's some people know where
they stand in life and there's some
people don't know what they're standing
like or they know where they stand like
they just don't want to believe it they
just don't want to believe it Lee and
it's a shame it's a big shocker when it
happened it shouldn't shock you man
you know you said something interesting
if a comedy club owner was to say listen
man I know comedy club owners that hate
[ __ ] black people more than [ __ ]
down sterling but they do black shows
they're you know what the owners leave
on those nights they're not there they
don't give a [ __ ] you know and they they
make money they make cash registers off
the black people cash register with
those sold nights and freedom Mondays
and all that [ __ ] [ __ ] you know and
they don't give a [ __ ] you got to assume
these [ __ ] this some people
actually care for the human race and
they [ __ ] yesterday I went to church
you know oh my little [ __ ] girl and
and at the end of church I went you know
you put him in daycare my wife goes
upstairs and I said they can't watch him
alone Wow hey and there was the cutest
little black girl that I just want to go
over and hug her and listen man it's not
racism but even at that age they know
this kids different yeah there was six
white kids in one black girl she was
innocent she didn't know she
no but sometimes racism comes in the
form of ignorance it always is it's just
ignorance you know I would be ignorant
of Jasper Williams didn't take my hand
those days in Harlem I would be very
ignorant of Jasper Williams never walked
me up to his [ __ ] building and ate
with me like it I don't know their
family had no [ __ ] money my family
had money
I remember going up there and taking out
like a $10 bill when I was five and
they're all looking at me like what a
[ __ ] you got a $10 bill from and I give
him money go buy sodas because if my
mother taught me as a young man when you
go to somebody's house even that's
[ __ ] five I knew that you went down
and got the $10 worth of soda I bring
I'm gonna bring him Pepsi up to their
house and thinking black people like
Pepsi you know I like [ __ ] coke but
down Saturday night someone opened their
couches for me we were dead and then
they were looked at me as being a [ __ ]
or is being a [ __ ] honky or whatever
they were opening their culture to me
and I never forgot that Lee I never ever
forgot that man never I could think of
all my little black friends growing up
at Catholic school as a Rito Falah and
just all these little black kids that
how I don't know I gave them extra love
and attention you know I always liked
the underdog I believe in you know cuz
I'm a [ __ ] on the dog you know but I
think of those times man with that black
family what they did for me and what how
I can never think that way and I can
never think that way about and I talk a
lot of [ __ ] dog I talk a lot of [ __ ] I'm
the first one to tell you I'll talk [ __ ]
just for the laugh sometimes because the
word Hindu is funny any signal or an end
it was [ __ ] funny yeah but man you
know there's a kid who came I met at the
[ __ ] a weed store I have Hindu
friends man I don't give a [ __ ] what
they are at the end of the day you know
that mean why if you're my brother
we're brothers at the end yeah you need
a gun let's go get a gun and shoot peas
and [ __ ] together because I
know I get the same from you yeah what's
up [ __ ] yo what's up little
brother me yeah it's me what's happening
hey why do you call me Joe after 30
[ __ ] years I told you about this
early it's either cocoa or beers yeah I
know you don't like coke no I like cocoa
I don't like Joe
oh [ __ ] I don't like when people from
old-school people that I hate chicken
cutlets at their house and fed me I
don't like when they call me [ __ ]
Joey
all right you people know what your
father used to call me goggle up oh
right yeah what's up baby
uh you don't say working like the slave
don't say that today please
I got a problem with uh with
what's-his-name the coach of the [ __ ]
of the owner of the [ __ ] LA Clippers
what's up timmy you know I love you we
talk once a week we've been friends for
a long time and it's funny Timmy always
calls me and says hey man you know I
listen to the podcast and when you were
talking about being a kid on this block
I remember that or what happened to that
guy and it really inspires me to me it
really does something to me when one of
the kids I grew up with first of all I
still talk to you you know I was very
tight of your brother but I still talk
to you a lot and that you like the show
you like what we're doing in the stories
move you you know yeah um you know I've
been since 84 85 so what did that feels
like thirty years and I've always been a
big fan of talk radio Stern
ona and now with the podcast you know I
got tons of on my phone but you know the
regulars I listen to you Rogan and jim
Florentine I like but uh let's go to
your show I it's weird because you bring
up names from the past and people I have
in photos and so long and just like kind
of forgot about that there we say even
in my life or I even let them like what
you talked about in the fourth I forgot
not that guy and then when I start
thinking about him I think about it many
times they can grab it it looks like a
guitars for a mom to cook yeah that
could be a balloon water you know it's
uh it's weirding me to calling and
beyond so it's really
because I never wanted to call into like
a culture I mean I mean I listens but my
disability is the talk radio and I never
wanted to be a also for me to call in
and talk and hear myself on a radio is
[ __ ] crazy you know and to see you
you know acting in movies with the Niro
you know the guy G vacuous it's like
it's [ __ ] balls in your way I'm sorry
it blows me away because he's a guy
growing up and he been you know we can
cause father - man time will be so great
and so you'd be in his presence I know
he did the regular guy puts it there so
I'm gonna get I know that's up still
it's been here all day
you know and you to have that success
and stuff like that and you made it you
know we never look for that stuff to be
younger we feels crazy was just
constantly getting high drugs and
laughing and all like not since we
didn't mean your kids it's Timmy its I
still remember going to see
48 hours with your brother you know I
remember seeing Nick Nolte would they
had a store I'm just thinking about your
brother Bernie and Glen currently in the
dead of winter going to see that movie
I'm laughing our [ __ ] asses off you
know that that's what it crazy me that I
went to see these guys with you guys you
know I want the movies with you guys and
now I'm standing next to these guys it's
[ __ ] crazy and for me I just laugh
Timmy I laugh because if they only knew
if they only have people only [ __ ] them
really knew like these people is this
podcast and still probably go
you know what the [ __ ] Joey we like you
you don't they don't know Timmy they
don't know that you know I used to snort
coke under that rocket ship on ADHD
field and you know but that little
rocket ship I remember doing an
Eightball my nose is bleeding and crying
because I didn't know what my life is
gonna change you know and it's amazing
today I'm not uh I'm not a millionaire
I'm not financially none of that [ __ ]
but you know that I'm rich in life like
what happened here is a [ __ ]
once-in-a-lifetime especially the guys
like us man it's it's
it's if yeah okay go ahead no no I just
stinking those Sunday dinners at your
house with your grandmother if I were to
pop my head up at one of those Sunday
dinners I looked at all using go Hey
not for nothing I'm happy you Irish and
German [ __ ] fed me but in 30
years I'm a double with dinero you
grandmother woulda thrown a [ __ ] can
at me done she wouldn't smell [ __ ] at me
so toss Jimmy this is [ __ ] out of
this world
this is unbelievable I remember the time
when the the water broke in Jersey City
I took your brother down for the show
and he got burnt to death with a suntan
remember and we took back and your
grandmother was in the living room and
your brother was [ __ ] purple from the
Sun he was purple they kept putting that
yellow Weightman out of them what's that
pink [ __ ] what's that big [ __ ] oh my god
you know how am i calamine lotion right
they kept putting down my lotion so your
grandmother I get down there and I'm
like what's up Roger you coming Hank or
nowhere look with your mother [ __ ]
did for me yesterday I'm already oh and
the whole time he's young as your
grandmother he's at the dinner table
drinking a beer going like this put
Noxzema she kept saying look knock see
my on it and your brother kept saying it
and looking at your grandmother and then
he kept looking back with copal how am I
gonna go out tonight and your
grandmother kept saying put Maxime on it
and he looked at your grandma say Maxime
a one more [ __ ] time my day and your
father's like Roger relax
she keeps saying [ __ ] like Seema
Seema you know Jimmy he couldn't be
Jimmy he couldn't be we've had this
conversation about your brother before
he could not be we could not
you to do him when confit and ferny live
in this other world now because I'm the
only one that could believe what
happened I think you know why because I
put my mother in the casket of 15 and I
believe that anything to [ __ ] happen
at any time in this life
Glenn Conti listens to Joel Osteen now
can you believe that my brother Glenn
County who was in the car with us who
did blow and ran over hookers you know
you got your brother last time I saw
your brother I said - ma you still
banging hookers and he goes no now I let
them jerk me off with their feet you
understand me these are the guys Frannie
I don't know what happened to him but if
people understood that year and a half
with us to read ed together well that's
for did together me your brother and
those two guys you know tell me this
morning when I was thinking of calling
it I was sitting there drinking coffee
one day and I have to tell you the truth
if somebody came to me today
some white guy with greasy hair in a
suit and a [ __ ] croissant and he said
to me Coco I got a deal for you I'm
gonna give you one night with fur neat
Karthi and Roger you're gonna meet at 8
o'clock I'm gonna give you all the blow
the quaaludes whatever the [ __ ] you want
I'm gonna give you a car it's not gonna
get pulled over but at the end of the
night you die and you have to walk away
from all this I'd have to tell him to
give me 24 hours because I have to think
about it that's how much I miss those
guys in that camaraderie like it was
Twiggy and you know you gotta remember
Timmy my mother had just died if it
wasn't for your brother and those guys
and your family with the Maxine the
stories and all that [ __ ] I wouldn't be
a man I would have been in a safe they
really they they that's where I remember
my most memories if you were me you and
guys sitting running basement
remember behind the firewalls
we have to climb climb over lucky very
underwear oh my god they had six feet of
[ __ ] laundry downstairs your brother
used to go I would go downstairs man a
high heard all over the [ __ ] clothing
is weird it's just you look back on
someone stopping and like it's not real
you feel like some of it's not real it
didn't happen and then you think it's it
I remember it it happened but you get
that weird feeling it's like you didn't
do I don't know I hope you feel the same
way I do I know everything like I'm not
Burgundy so [ __ ] up up years gone by
with all the drugs and everything you
know just being I haven't had a drink
since 2001 but you know I smoked a
little weed in an airing you know I
can't because my job but they you you
just can't go back you know what I mean
growing up is tough you know I mean to
be a man and a father and all that stuff
not easy
it's really not easy and to be out there
with responsibilities and stuff like
that no no tell me it's not I know we
did it for that we push we push the drug
Hill to it listen man I have a baby girl
I have a 16 month old baby girl it's
over but listen to me I had this
opportunity once before and I don't
[ __ ] remember it I don't remember
changing diapers you know me and that
little girl don't talk today and I don't
blame her because I don't remember a lot
of things because I put cocaine first
you know and a lot of people do that in
the beginning that they try to get their
life back I got a second chance 10 I'm
the second chance guy you know I keep
getting second [ __ ] chances in life
and I you know do the best I can with
them but I don't remember you know so I
know that when you have a child right
now I quit smoking two months ago
I don't know why I don't know I didn't
want it in the house no more I was sick
and tired of having it in my lungs but
the other hand I want
look her in the face and times you know
I wanna I wanted to be real you know and
not attempt what my point was with your
brother before and those guys in the car
is that I missed those time so much it
hurts I missed those guys so much it
hurts and it's 30 years later I missed
those guys
I've been talking to ferny's brother
online but I still haven't busted the
question yet how your brother's doing
because I don't know how he's gonna
react
you know ferny put a lot of his blame of
his life on me and us she's a beautiful
while and and I said I told you I've
seen him I guess and what have been the
early nineties he's working the Leos all
Balkan that restaurant is working as a
cook in the back there and I don't know
what happened to him after that I
haven't seen them but yes honey was a
good kid man he's quiet you know he was
a really good player I I know instance
when I moved up to 64th Street and when
I think I was a fourth or fifth grade
and you were probably that's when you
first moved into North Bergen I'm over
73 but I didn't go I'm not burden for
like 75 was when I went to McKinley yeah
I really love you from the best walk was
pursued from my bounce house remember
when I was a kid seeing you down you
know with snow blowers and all them guys
you know all them other guys the Bendis
and all them guys they loose you guys
you a couple walks away from us but it's
all it's it's the posing waiting here
you know the things that you talk about
because it brings it back so vividly you
know what I mean and it's uh sometimes I
just I have to stop the truck in there
and I find myself you know like almost
you know crying because I miss it too
but you know what I went through to get
old so it was it was the living a lie to
go down to Florida for months and detox
or suppose it's as hell and you know
gradually doing the same thing we were
in deep
and you know and still today you know I
have really bad back pain some driving
this truck all day and you know I
struggled me and I struggle with it and
you know it's to be clean and sober and
clear minded is one of the greatest
things in the world but for drug addicts
like me and you you know what I mean we
still savor the drug thing like they say
we want to go back with a half pound of
coke if that's such a thing so only a
drug addict would think like that you
know what I mean and that's but that's
the way I think and that's where I feel
so you know I would if I want to go back
and would like I always say to myself
like spa life again I'm still doing
drugs again but I wouldn't get it there
instead of safety so I'll never touch
drugs again I say I'd go back and follow
that but I would easy with the drugs
which is in st. Paul I'm a drug addict
I've never taken you know what I mean so
that's just a it's ingrained in me it's
the way we grew up it's our generation
you know this generation coming up I
don't know my son's
who knows what's gonna happen Joe I
don't know it's a crazy world out there
I really don't know man you know it's
crazy because I stopped doing the coke
and the pills but the transfer addiction
I went over to reefer I felt that was
the that was the way I was the safest
was with reefer you know and when I say
I would go back I mean I don't think I
could ever do a line of coke again or a
pill oh I got ecstasy at the house I got
pills at the house I look at them you
know once a week and go whoa what am I
gonna give this away just to sit with
them just to sit with them and drive for
an hour and talk about where our eyes
went and what happened and you know it
would be great to see them you know when
I go home I always think of calling Raja
but I know deep down inside me and Roger
best friends from afar you know I'm
saying I know that Roger would be
uncomfortable if I went and tried to
smother his private life I know that
Roger would feel very uncomfortable
after three minutes you have nowhere to
go no I know and listen the most
important clothes
the most important thing about life is
knowing where you stand if you don't
know where you stand with your people
and your friends it's gonna be a night
man I love Roger to death
but I would never call rides and say hey
where's your address I'm on my way
because he will have a nervous breakdown
and he's been doing that since he was a
kid but now at least 20 years or I go to
eat with him remember when you go to eat
with him it was always fun he would
torture people while he was eating and
whatever he wouldn't even do that now I
get him to loosen up I could get him to
loosen up not to smoke pot nothing like
that but I could get him to laugh and to
crack a racist joke or something he was
always good for something but it's it's
really weird that in this day and age to
me I still call you you call me we laugh
you'll say you told that story the other
day that was [ __ ] up you know I forgot
all about that we grew up hey listen man
I don't know what the [ __ ] I am I don't
know but I tell you one thing we met a
lot of interesting people growing up I
know I did yeah yeah and just in our
[ __ ] blocks just just you know I
still member was the most popular
neighborhood for crazy people in our
neighborhood was 64 you filled for a lot
of people who know North Bergen or may
not know nothing that's like eight parks
with kids used to hang on it but the one
that had the worst reputation or 64th
Street field and every time you walk
past it you always had to be prepared
like some kids like we're gonna walk
past it real quick and look straight
don't look at them don't look at them
you know but there was Iraq the rocks
I still remember one night snortin
called - Randy Merkel's house until 5:30
in the morning and going we gotta go for
a walk mayhem D'Agostino and it we had
to be there at 7:00 in the morning at
school I used to go to school first
period I had CIU work study program I'm
a [ __ ] junior and it's 5:30 in the
morning again for your people at home
I'm a junior in high school it's 5:30 in
the morning with snorting coke at
somebody's house the first classes at
7:30 this is why I'm [ __ ] up this is
why this podcast is crazy and I remember
making a right on that corner by Lincoln
school and walking down to the field and
thinking I was just going
there and seeing Corky and 20 other
people on the rocks with their shirts on
from going to work the day before I
thought I was doing something cool but
there was 20 other [ __ ] people that
were men that were already out still
drinking for the night before they
hadn't even gone home after [ __ ] work
yeah well when guys were that was Corky
the Worthington brothers my wife's
family darling Billy darling I'm dialing
all them guys yeah they were the next
level up from us you know Randy you mean
Randy and the calmest baby calm is Joey
Thomas Davy Thomas will here taught me
how to go Frank bangin that's who went
[ __ ] bangin first he's the first guy to
tie up some guy he tied up the piano
player from long as well he's the first
guy ever to [ __ ] cause damage on 64
you filming these kids were [ __ ] crazy
but these kids nobody was rich any
Holloway correct and no correct
nobody was rich bro there was a couple
of I had money uptown but besides there
would be fought for themselves and if
anybody found that you had money we try
to take it like no I don't know without
you jack we jack you for attending
something if we knew you had a 50 on yet
we had to walk with a 10 with something
you know I I just I could write a book
about the two years I spent with Roger
and how many laughs I had and how many
times man I wasn't sure about my life
but Roger made me laugh and it made me
forget about I remember the night that
Gwen can't be beat that kid up and broke
his jaw and two nights later I get a
call from Raji's that he said he's a
great Gregory seven-day weekend and he's
going crazy
this is when your brother was definitely
the funniest man in America he still is
this is right around the time he pulled
up at the car and you left the lights on
the blinkers on and he came and he goes
tell you what's the circus coming to
town turn the [ __ ] blink I'll never
forget that statement but we were at
Corky yeah yeah yeah it's weed I don't I
I can hardly remember that far back name
all the abuse to my brain I and I I know
you're talking about but I can hardly
remember it because I know it happened
and it's bad but
you can't close your eyes to me for one
second cause you're [ __ ] oh no he's
not that won't
oh no no no look at me I'm not that guy
anymore I'm not the guy who used to call
you and say pick me up or going on a
[ __ ] ride to me you know give me back
of my car oh we wouldn't I wouldn't I
wouldn't that to nobody anymore
but it's so funny that uh Glenn Conti
had just broken that kid's jaw I don't
remember what the kid's name wasn't his
jaw was wired up he was at Cork he's
waiting for Glenn Conti there was a
little bounty waiting for Glenn County
and your brother the balls on your
brother he walked right into the storm
eight o'clock you know people used to go
out at 10:00 then not your brother he
went on a date he wasn't good to jump on
a night
and he would call me up over Louisville
where you at him of Corky's come on up I
just got a package come on up here and I
remember walking in and the Johnnie vest
was working do you remember the
bartender Johnny or vest they call them
Johnny vest right and your brother at
that time was a professional bartender
killer okay if there was a bar time that
your job your brother's job was to
torture him till the guy quit he did it
to the guide to Mike I remember he had
that Chinese restaurant he used to call
the guy over in karate chop he used to
pay a Chinese guy it's a little karate
chopping you walked into the mic Connie
go watch this come in the guy would walk
over and a guy would put his neck down
and Rajal go ha you can't write that
[ __ ] you can't write that [ __ ] Roger
give him like a ten is it time to karate
chop you won so we're at this [ __ ]
Gregory 7 Day weekend that was the name
of the barn I walk in and they're all
looking at me because I'm going coffee's
fine Glen Conti broke this guy's jaw on
Monday night it's Wednesday who goes out
of the [ __ ] Wednesday with an eight
ball I woke up and in those days your
brother used to smash the ashtrays
at the bar you know I'm a little black
plastic ashtrays Timmy he would bang him
on the bar until they broke in half and
the guy would just keep breaking and
putting away why would you put the last
tray up there and him he
carry away and pick up the ashtray and
start banging johnny vest give me a
double give this [ __ ] a double to
give dick coke all up we'll get over
here and yell couples in the house put
your wallets in your front pocket
you know you'd always say that he would
always say that wallets in front pockets
wallets and front pockets couple of cow
and all of a sudden he started hitting
me ashtray him and the guy that had that
broke that doing confit had broken his
jaw was wired up sitting right next to
Roger and Roger is looking but he's
close to Roger like he's listening to
Rogers conversation and Rogers looking
at me and he's [ __ ] hitting that the
days that Kokomo comes in the house coco
loco's in the house and also he's like
how you doing buddy now you hit your ass
and go how you doing buddy and one of
those how you doing buddies he looks
over at this guy and the guys look let
me goes what do you want a jawbreaker
and he looks right back he asked this
[ __ ] will you want a jawbreaker
anyone right back to me like he hadn't
said nothing and I just had to keep it
[ __ ] together and laugh my ass off
man
but Timmy I'm happy that up you know you
always call the show and you stole my
friend and you got me lost last time on
the way the hearty length but you know
Timmy after all these years was your
friend's brother and I love you to all
my heart and I love that you're still in
my life man I really I wouldn't know
what to do if you weren't in my life we
have friends we talked about we talked
about my man guys Tabasco and you know
but we come from us you know Jimmy and
I'll tell you why I miss that time
because I don't have that normal if I
had that camaraderie right now I'd be a
different man out here you know if I had
Darrin Rago still alive I'd be I had to
have a different man I'd be a different
man you know he was even he was very
close to me just before we died and I
seen him he was he was uh he wasn't
himself because he was married with a
kid and he didn't want to be there
anything you know what I mean but he was
trying to
she was trying to tame him no no she was
a pro woman's job is to tame us
it's just that what time you walk into
our life whatever I went out you know
what I mean is said but he was destined
for something bad to happen to him he
was really wild that kid them to stop
that none of us well I know you know
more than I do but you know I crazy [ __ ]
you know it's funny I have a picture him
on my wall I'm gonna have a little thing
but on Monday
I read Monday I put water out for the
spirits and I want a candle for him in
fact on the way here I think I left the
candle early I don't want the house to
burn down and I look at their pictures
and I look at all of them daring Dominic
speciality Bolzano my mother you know I
look at my friend's daughter Emma I have
all that pictures out there and I think
about the men and those guys give me
strength because they're not here but I
know they're watching over me you know I
know that Darren watches over me and I
know that that's a Bolzano you know I
think about these guys I keep these guys
alive in my heart and it makes me strong
it makes me stronger than [ __ ] death
to keep these guys alive because it's
all I have
you know I really it's so weird I keep
these memories alive because it keeps me
moving forward it reminds me who the
[ __ ] I am I never ever wanted to forget
who the [ __ ] I was man never it gave me
so much strength growing up with you
guys I never want to forget so uh thank
you for calling me and thank you for
always digging the podcast and [ __ ]
brother yeah it's a great like I said
before I uh I know radio because I've
been listening for years and like I said
last week thing that lady you guys you
guys were getting loud and that lady
knocked on the door that was that was
just that was great radio and I was
laughing my and it's really if it's a
good show good to know and uh [ __ ] weeks
excuse me engage know what I mean II
think they'd get something about it that
I love listening out
I don't know because I know all the
stories and I know all people but it it
is a good radio show and uh I hope you
have continued successful
I love you brother now wha you know I'm
happy that you still contact me and we
call each other and we [ __ ] around and
we giggle with me you know I like when
you call me after a podcast and go hey
man when you were talking about that the
other day I remember that situation well
you're my buddy and I'm happy that you
called it a Monday and we'll talk soon
my friend give my best to your family
always brother stay black on black
that's the real deal brother that's
that's as real as it gets
what do you want a job break and then he
went right back to me like nothing
happened
and the guy's face just turned that was
you know was amazing that you guys
always send me emails and say man you
know thank you I was on oxycontin I was
on heroin I lost 200 pounds you guys
send me all these [ __ ] emails you
want to thank me and Lee I gotta tell
you something I want to thank you guys
because since I've done this you keep me
on my [ __ ] toes I've become a better
stand-up I become a better man I've
become a better father I've become a
better person all around because you
guys keep me on my [ __ ] toes man so
when you guys come to the shows and give
me a hug and you buy a stupid [ __ ]
mug or a patch you let me know that the
little world I believe in is still a
while it's still around if there's good
[ __ ] people out there there's people
that [ __ ] up and now we're scratching
to come back on in the meantime we're
[ __ ] doing all the right things we
put up blinkers on we make a left or
right would pick up garbage you pay our
taxes we take the garbage out you know
these are the [ __ ] things you got to
do man it's never be things that you
have to do all these other things to be
successful and it all starts with little
[ __ ] things man you know there's
little things
being a better friend torturing Lee make
him eat an edible every day making your
friend walk making your friends better
Joe Rogan did when he opened up the door
for us you know instead of for us to be
better man he he wanted me to be better
and Harley be better and Duncan and
happen so now we're opening up the
floodgates and the next one is you you
know everybody has you know the other
day I was talking to Li Hao I went to
get gas at five in the morning before I
went to the airport and I saw a guy
maybe ten years younger than me baby for
he pumping gas outside smoking a
cigarette and as I was pumping the gas I
saw he had two assistants in the truck
two young guys you know 18 19 and they
were just sitting man that both had this
look on their face like what the [ __ ]
are we doing here you know and it's the
same look I had on my face when I was
that age because you're like what the
[ __ ] am I gonna do is this my life is
this my future and you look at the guy
that is driving the truck your crew
leader and this guy is no [ __ ] yeah
you know this guy's no Einstein
look I'm thinking this is gonna be my
life and the guy gets back in the truck
and tells you if you work hard you're
gonna be able to buy your own house look
at me I got a two-bedroom flat and you
know and he's selling young you look
like this guy like this guy is [ __ ]
delusional but at the same time he's
very proud of what he's done but we
don't look at it that way we look at it
the guy's a waste of time
he's this guy's been working hard for 20
years and what does he have a [ __ ]
boat and a [ __ ] house and he works
six days a week
I could sell drugs I could do this we
always think of a shortcut I always took
the shortcut I'm not gonna lie nobody
always thought I could do better than
this guy but I had to sell drugs I had
to rob somebody you know it's so weird I
remember that feeling I was telling we
don't leave does a podcast about dies or
the 25 and I'm then what they go through
and that's I think that's the biggest
[ __ ] thing this confusion and fear
and I didn't have it because of these
guys I never thought about it because of
these guys these guys were such an
effect on me from Roger Holloway though
I mean he was fearless I had two guys in
my life that did not give a [ __ ] about
their surroundings and they would let
you know what was on their mind and if
you crossed them they would [ __ ]
fight you to the end it was gonna be a
nightmare for you mom was Roger Holloway
it was no tough
and the other one was Mike Lonnie I
learned from them so much and this is
why the fracture all those years when I
was young I didn't have nothing and I
doubt myself because of the people I had
around me
so I keep them close by because if they
help me then they keep me together now
even with a little conversation a little
[ __ ] call you know I'm saying so I'm
very proud of that today but I'm proud
of you guys thank before I love you give
me in the respect and Lee that's amazing
we could never be a racist every [ __ ]
city I go to there's always the biggest
blackest guy comes up to me there's more
[ __ ] leak it is amazing I had three
[ __ ] doors I had three black doors
come up to me and Baltimore asking me my
[ __ ] Lee with Leah with Leah people
always asked her in Liana it's always
big black burly [ __ ] I love it
so you couldn't be racist even if you
wanted and i'ma for Jimmy call doesn't
ask you the only time I ever thought
about it and not being racist but I
thought about with my last girlfriend I
thought about what Paula is like when
you when you're kid growing up you never
imagined you always imagined a kid being
white now Paula my kids aren't gonna be
if I have kids Apollo they're not gonna
be what I was I'm interested in what
like your wife thinks well because your
wife comes from Tennessee I don't think
she ever thought she's gonna be have a
killer the Cuban guy I don't think her
family ever thought that so I'd be
interested I don't think she's racist
but I can't imagine that's what she
imagined love is love yeah love is love
man you know and now sometimes I see a
hot real Japanese white guy is something
and I giggle and I go love is love love
doesn't have color barriers like all
these white people are all up in arms I
can't believe Donald sterling but how
many of them if they brought a clipper
home like a black guy home and with a
white girl how many other dads like mmm
like I mean it's it that that's what
that's not the part that annoys me is
people when I said earlier that I think
with each generation people are getting
less racist I actually think people are
getting more hiding it more that's like
more PC because like I know people from
the home
like like the girl like there's always
like there's that one white girl who
only dates black guys and it's just
people talking about it it's just it's
that's just the world we live in
like I said I talk a lot of [ __ ] but I
you'll never be racist just because of
my you know my admiration all the
different races and what they have to
bring for the table well I took from
them what I took from them what I took
from them you know I took a lot from
black humour you know I took a lot from
I take a lot man I read my I love so it
but I also before something sad or
something I always think of a struggle
you know because I had the same struggle
may be in my heart may be you know I
don't know the only time I thought about
racism was one time in Jersey mr.
Fontana gym teacher two kids were
talking in Spanish
Peter Jimenez and somebody else and he
made them walk home because he told me
this is America and I remember how the
kids reacted and me going home Tom my
mother my mother's like you know what I
don't agree with him making the kids
walked but I agree with him for what he
said I understand or it's coming from
you can't be mad I'm he's trying to make
you an American and make you better or
something so it's how we [ __ ] teachers
who balls ain't had to come to Turin
that was two incidents the only twin
instance I've had in my life and that's
why I don't let racism affect me I don't
let racism bother me when I see it it
bothers me but what the [ __ ] are you
gonna do if you leave the house thinking
that all these people you come in
contact with a not racist you got a big
[ __ ] surprise coming to you yeah you
know you gotta assume that 50% of the
people walking around a two-face from
other [ __ ] two-faced [ __ ] 50
percent and I'm being generous on that
number I'm talking about people who
don't like you and I'll smoke your weed
people you know I was not raised to be
that way I was if I didn't like your how
to primary I stay the [ __ ] away from you
I don't hang out we always have a party
don't say
he's got tons of money let's go [ __ ]
like Hindus who cares he'll cover his
feet no you know I'm just saying I'm
just making a [ __ ] example that's how
I was raised
you don't like somebody or you don't
like somebody's politics you stay the
[ __ ] away from yeah then tell your
society people don't give a [ __ ] people
do not give a [ __ ] you know I really
appreciate the Rogan show the other
night because there's Joey Diaz fans
mm-hmm and there's people that don't
want to talk to me on the Rogan fans
they're too smart
Rogan has a section as fans Lee just too
smart they just you know the too
intelligent they they they they're too
[ __ ] smart they you know they think
of everything you know he gave kept to
the coke for the caddy he must be a
fella you know like I said people
practice and me because I'm a fountain
yeah you're a felon it's just another
word for being black that's why I tell
people to stay the [ __ ] black there's no
matter what I do I always have the stink
of a felon on me why do you think I
never went did the paper to get the
felony thinking all hung give a [ __ ]
because I can hide it but it's in my
walk it's in my style
it's who the [ __ ] I am and I can either
hide it and put it away like a shame
like most people in this country do to
her ashamed of the mistakes they've made
I put it out there so when I say
something you know you go I know why he
said that
I know why he means that I know where
he's coming from
so as far as I'm concerned I ain't going
no [ __ ] clipper games either [ __ ] him
[ __ ] him I want to give out some [ __ ]
who are you saying mom you're just not
going cuz it's 200 it's too expensive
I don't give a [ __ ] I want to give a
shout-out to my favorite [ __ ]
[ __ ] Chun Kennedy last name it can
the other matter [ __ ] that happened a
bad [ __ ] guineas ano I love you
[ __ ] Jesse in Ontario thank you
for the love toxic get it together
[ __ ] toxic is one guy that hit me
up remember seven B C's one's ever said
B see you guys I think he was locked up
he came out he had no money and I
understood so I sent them a letter
explain to him the Teflon Jew I always
loved your notion Diego Jordan Ryan
grads B and Chris I rent I love you
[ __ ] you know he the church
would snap Allah now eatin ass in 73
that's our new motto you understand me
some people have a model
20 million burgers served I don't give a
[ __ ] who's making people fat the church
or what's happening now heat mass so 73
no Joey who's asked in you eat when you
attend the girl upstairs Ivette Torres
we used to wake up in the morning on a
[ __ ] I didn't she'd let me smell it and
lick in the [ __ ] let me say something
you [ __ ] people in Texas I love Texas
I love for everything that you stand for
I'm a fat [ __ ] I belong that I can't
wait the girls trying to buy some
clothes if it's 2x and Texas is [ __ ]
huge oh really
o to X here we take a little [ __ ]
skinny person that's how they get you
you buy a 2x and [ __ ] Texas see what
it looks like looks like a [ __ ]
blanket 4x in Texas is like [ __ ] the
sizes building it's amazing when you buy
clothes and [ __ ] Texas it's
completely [ __ ] bigger all those
numbers they give you at sea is and and
Walmart throws a figure and Peter
[ __ ] fat people you understand me and
got fluoride in their system ok that
[ __ ] down a [ __ ] text you gonna see
the clothes they have for fat people
because when you when you're fat and
you're gonna [ __ ] big and tall all
those stores and you travel they have
your clothes I mean you go to Chicago
and you see a fat guy he's got the same
shirt as you want okay look at each
other like to [ __ ] jerk clothes we
talked about this before in Texas they
got fat tailors for fat people
you'll get clothes and nobody else in
the world has oh [ __ ]
but history thing about Texas so I'm not
saying that
tonio Houston in Dallas I love you guys
if you want to come see me this year I
love to see you do me a [ __ ] favor
come to Austin the 15th through the 17th
that's all I'm funny because I got no
other dates in Texas The Improv Houston
or Dallas ain't gonna put me in there
San Antonio hasn't gotten back to us so
it's [ __ ] Austin so if you haven't
[ __ ] seen me all year and you want to
have a good time you want to smoke some
vapor hits need some pot cookies and get
Li the [ __ ] give you a back rub come
on down Austin that's all I'm saying I'm
not even advertising it's a [ __ ] top
I don't want to hear you either what are
you coming to Dallas ain't coming to
[ __ ] Dallas and I ain't coming to
[ __ ] Houston okay right now it's not
in the books really do it vet myself
there get a tent so I can go down there
for zoom myself in I can't Austin's
where it's at
not
this week not the week after but the
week after the flying Jews coming with
me [ __ ] the weekend this week I'm the
Santa Barbara Rovers but the week after
that I'm in Santa Fe at the Camelback
[ __ ] casino eight o'clock Saturday
night on my man Ari Shaffir what's with
the questions I don't know he used back
rubs - what are you fear - you know he
doesn't know I don't give back don't
like people and I don't know why there's
no statements he didn't ask me to do
this or anything
Edwyn San Juans in the Pachanga comedy
club this bliss we get my second and
third because I was just looking at his
Twitter
No will you push some buttons for well
mind you what's the question - that's my
whole thing I press buttons when I want
you to me thing I want you to find the
last two minutes of dogs might think for
if that's the anthem of the day today
I'm gonna give some shoutouts to my
[ __ ] tremendous sponsors on it that's
always there for me
on Acamas been there since the beginning
I didn't know what they were about Joe
Rogan sold them for me a little bit told
me about them then I started taking on
and I'll tell you what the Alpha brand
thank you for that the turn around 180 s
if you fly a lot if you're a businessman
and you fly a lot and you don't want
that that little last bit people call it
jet lag I don't know what the [ __ ] of
this be get that last bit of tiredness
you can't shake trickle 180 or change
your whole [ __ ] life protein the hemp
protein you can't [ __ ] beat it 16
grams of protein it tastes delicious I
like the chocolate but the acai vanilla
is not bad either go with the chocolate
[ __ ] tremendous you won't [ __ ] blood
list it yeah no no no missed my you
should mix it I like my yeah I don't
know how would taste I'm not the thing
would blow up protein powder next you
know I'm missing a finger like some
[ __ ] Arab guy because of missing
[ __ ] protein powders and [ __ ] my
point is honest data take care of you
they have a money-back guarantee they
have digestive enzymes
they've got kettlebells do me a favor
just going on and look at the webpage I
don't even know what's in the Schrute
export which I'm a fat [ __ ] give me
extra 20 minutes I'm sore the next day
there's nothing you can do that's why
you pop the strong bone or you drink the
[ __ ] whatever else they have for
soreness but as far as energy real
[ __ ] energy along anything that he's
gonna be jittery and [ __ ] like that the
shroom tech sport I can't [ __ ] push
it enough and the shroom tech mu if you
fly a lot or if you're in weird
situations you're a coach around a lot
of kids when you're around a lot of kids
and I was like the [ __ ] flu don't be
that [ __ ] taste room tech sport
all right go to on it go to Hana calm if
you like on your own look around what
they have is you gotta order some go to
Joey Diaz done that see if I'm gonna be
in your town and put what in the box
church Church CH you are CH in the box
and you get 10% off look into the stay
on it program they'll mail you the stuff
tea house at the first every month like
Thursday you've got a whole new [ __ ]
batch of whatever the [ __ ] you're doing
and they'll set it right the house and
you
and I'm giving you a ten extra for doing
that go to alikom today see what they
got to offer you're not gonna be sorry
from kettlebells the battle ropes too
[ __ ] grenades on it does it all
Hulu Plus you know what man again every
week I get emails from people who speak
I answered 92 [ __ ] emails that was
the most of my three or four weeks Wow
and I got to tell you five of those
emails or people thanking me they're
about Dollar Shave Club or Hulu Plus did
know about it you know I didn't know
about things like Hulu Plus least tell
me about all the other companies but
once Hulu Plus looked into us and we
looked into them we loved it
they got shows that kill it's not
hulu.com it's Hulu Plus for a [ __ ]
reason they got your favorite show shark
tank daily show
they got shows you want to binge you
want to catch up on stuff you know some
people work all [ __ ] they ain't got
time to watch TV every night but Sunday
you want to smoke 15 joints on watch six
episodes Hulu Plus has that for you it's
for people want to binge and hang out
and isn't the beauty is it's $7.99 a
month you think that you compare that to
the rest of [ __ ] that's going on your
way $7.99 a month that's two dollars a
week the wife 20,000 [ __ ] shows games
documentaries movies got a Hulu Plus com
go to Joey beers that neck go to Hulu
Plus box and press send Joey
boom Jo ey get two weeks gratis boom I'm
the [ __ ] on who gives you that off the
back you ever go buy weed the guy gives
your joint says try that and come back
later no [ __ ] no you gotta pay up front
no money no ticket no sucky no [ __ ]
that's how it is old-school the same
thing with Hulu Plus but they give you
two weeks for free
checking the Hulu Plus right now Joey D
is what's in the box brother Joey Joey
Jo ey same thing with Dollar Shave Club
like I said every couple weeks I got a
bunch of emails people thanking me
didn't know they didn't know they didn't
know well now you know
for a dollar six dollars and nine
dollars you get tremendous [ __ ] razors
sent to your home you don't gotta leave
you know I'm gonna go to store you don't
go to send 11 and smell [ __ ] Hindu
toes you don't got do none of that [ __ ]
you go to [ __ ] Hulu Plus calm when you
press in a box Church Church CH you are
CH and you get the deal of a lifetime
you need to get raises for a dollar
six dollars or nine
a month six dollars a month is a great
package you get one stem sent the house
it's harder than [ __ ] hell
then they sing your two raises double
[ __ ] blades you understand me
what we what are you looking at you all
hypnotized I got that type of [ __ ]
handling magnetism kind of looking so
look at the screen as you believe our
six dollars a nine dollars plus they got
one wipe Charlies for you [ __ ]
let's say like I got the warm white
choice I say Pete I want my dick to
smell like peppermint I pulled the skin
back I [ __ ] massage that helmet with
this one chip one strip Charlie when I'm
on a plane three hours late I want to
smell my dick to make sure it don't
smell like dead Pete it smells like a
lifesaver
you understand me a peppermint like you
you'd smell like a lifesaver no good I
don't use one wipe my dick in a plane
you sit man air gets down it gets
trapped it's like a tunnel you got a
sniff your balls gotta go in there I go
on the bathroom open my zipper but then
I get you know what you should do you
should take one more Charley's on the
plane with you cuz what have you used to
subscribe them down there and then your
hand smells like dick like my hand saw
my dick they smell like dick I leave
order that's the air circulates I want
people to know what time it is - I'm
talking about get the whiff of that in
this [ __ ] main cabin [ __ ] in the air
the air circulates that has to see don't
because I stay on I wash them in the
morning I wash them in the afternoon I
wash them in I don't let the stink
develop I don't like that faux pas that
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] whatever
stink you just pack up it's just I'm
inking just when you back off and some
goes in your underwear some of those on
monkey but the other one stays on your
helmet you don't wash you back under one
with what you whack off with a wacko up
with anything on [ __ ] whatever you
got to do what you got to do when you're
a pet the meat you know saying anyway
go to [ __ ] Dollar Shave Club of
dollars six dollars pressing the box
Church church CH Urca
get your razor set the eyes now you go
Joey I got movies I got on it I'm
healthy and I got [ __ ] razors what do
I do now jump in a deprivation tank and
get your [ __ ] head together
escape pod tank and with me for three
months these male escape pod tank
dot-com these [ __ ] don't [ __ ]
around there are commercial tanks they
got residential tanks and you know what
you know what it gets better they come
to your house they deliver it they just
save you $2,000 to $3,000 on tanks I've
spoken to people customer service
supreme you call Jeremy on the 1-800
line he picks up like a [ __ ] soldier
hello
and he speaks English they say no no
habla [ __ ] with some [ __ ]
accent from another country jeremy is
[ __ ] American as can be in his house
he's got a picture of [ __ ] Kennedy
with a bullet going through his head
that's a [ __ ] American right there go
to escape pod tank calm correct correct
what the [ __ ] correcting me for
escape my tank comm whatever the [ __ ] I
smoked a couple [ __ ] vapors this
morning well you confuse a mission for
an escape pod tank comm for all your
[ __ ] deprivation tank needs they have
commercial ones residential just go to
the webpage see what they got
look around ask questions why [ __ ] go
and soak but other people don't wash
their ass they got fungi feet you know
their breath smells like dick we need to
do that your own house with your own
water go look into an escape pod tank
calm alright alright
what what what we what the [ __ ] is you
all stink I know I know right now I
can't can't believe we see your balls I
wash them when I stay on top if you
scratch on an airplane I gotta pee I
scratch my nuts right now that you
sniffing they smell like Irish Spring
what do you wanna make a bet there's
Irish playing these [ __ ] now
you don't want to wear it's all hot in
there no it's not this is what I do I
wash my balls at three different things
I got Irish Spring okay then I got the
loofah yeah with the coconut thing and
I'm scrubbing with that and I scrubbed
my [ __ ] to get all the barnacles away
so I'm no waste back there yeah then I
wash it then I hit it again I do my face
with the loofah get the dead skin your
ass first
yeah who gives a [ __ ] some people do
plastic surgery some people borrow the
skin from their ass I take the skin
cells and put them on my face yeah I'm
saying you gotta thank Lee I think you
know think about what what did you do
that's one ways [ __ ] skin so
everything [ __ ] creep in
take my [ __ ] soap in my hands and I
get in there with those [ __ ] nuts and
then I get the washcloth when I wash the
corners get I picked the wasp up I put
like the finger of my ass [ __ ] it's
like an inch goes this is an inch ready
you take that washcloth from your lip
around and now everything's fresh down
there so next two showers well I like
showers because that I know my boss
think I'm the first one to be honest
yeah but I control them kind of control
them control you take one bath today
yeah you can't do that with your ass
stinks like debt and when you wake up
you don't take a shower which means that
you have that dead ass that cultivates
in that [ __ ] anal cavity eight hours
while you sleep on that [ __ ] bed when
you wake up in the morning the first
thing you [ __ ] do is while you're
pissin is you turn that water on that's
what no I do normally when I have to
come here no but that's when you do it
even more
you get up 15 minutes early and you soak
that 19 minutes yeah you're in there 15
minutes at the hottest water possible
and 10 of those minutes it's pointment
your [ __ ] thing with steam coming out
of your nutsack no I was in 20 20
minutes whatever 2015 you know I'm
[ __ ] saying yeah you gotta make time
for this cleanliness is next to
godliness
no God will not yet let you into the
eternal flames of death hell whatever
unless your balls are [ __ ] washed you
cannot have a girlfriend if your balls
are not clean oh yeah no no you [ __ ]
go all day and then you pick up at 5:00
with that stinky nuts you got a woman
when you come home from that drive the
[ __ ] content wherever you go to pick
her up here while she's on the couch
kept excuse yourself and watch that ass
again that ass is cultivate you've been
sitting on that seat the asses you're
fightin it goes into the seat back up
into your [ __ ] ass how many times our
degree no yes three three that's a lot
of shower is that what are you gonna do
you want to be clean oh you want to be
like the rest of these [ __ ] maggots
walking around you ever smell somebody
bro oh yeah of course you want to smell
like that no then you gotta be wash
three showers you're a chubby dude you
at least owners like me yeah you ever
smell your shirts at the end of days my
cheeseburgers in [ __ ] Subway
sandwiches that's because it's the one
no cuz it comes out of my system you
don't want to work out every day
so when you sweat that ship that tops
where we think that smells like onions
and that harmless sweet weight if that
goes well for you then that stick
[ __ ] comes down this way comes out of
your sweat oh and it goes into your
clothes now you go take that shirt I'll
put it down and then you sit down go I
didn't do nothing yesterday I'm gonna
put that [ __ ] back oh no you
know what that shirt smells like and
then you tried it time you ever smell
somebody with sweat on this shirt
Cologne on top oh we have friends that
[ __ ] do that I don't want I'm around
when they do that [ __ ] they smelling
vomit
you got a wash you want you don't want
no problems take pre showers it you know
what I will do sometimes what will you
know I will change underwear half way
through the day
oh that's great not wash your [ __ ]
that's great so keep the stink and you
gotta transfer the [ __ ] addiction to
a new pair on the way yeah listen I'm
not gonna be sick well you gotta wash
your balls to put a fresh bear in the
world how can you know it's time to wash
three times a day you got to make time
this life is about making time if you
want to get forward you got to make time
to work out you got a mate time you know
what I [ __ ] hate connecting those
protein shakes but today I'm the way
back gotta stop at the protein store and
get protein powder man and the [ __ ]
thing to put in there I hate it it's 55
hours out of my pocket but I have to do
it these are the things you have to do
in your life you have to work on it this
[ __ ] just isn't gonna appear and these
all things that step into you being a
better person you start wake up in the
one you throw that hot water on while
you're getting your shoes that [ __ ]
shower is burning oh well Joey the water
is low I don't give a [ __ ] but that I
pay for it all right I pay for that
[ __ ] water put that bucket water on
you put that suppling water on this burn
you lay your socks on you look at your
shoes you clean the dog [ __ ] off you put
your pants down you put the shirt to
match while you're in there you go in
there you pick the [ __ ] razor and you
shave the top off over here so this is
even you do the rest of the shave in
that [ __ ] shower so it's one-stop
shopping my shower is one-stop shopping
so is that going to shower that hot
water hits me I wash my [ __ ] head I
take the [ __ ] thing and I watch
that's the first wash boom the ass the
boy and this is all three times I do
this not just once the balls defeat the
skin everything between the [ __ ] toes
you don't ever want to release those
axles those humus toxins in the
[ __ ] it I'm out of your ass then you
put conditioner in your hair while the
conditions in your hair settling you get
the [ __ ] shaving cream and you put on
your face nice in the shower and you
blast off in there with that steam so
it's very nice
you follow me by that time all those
barnacles off your [ __ ] yeah from you
eating McDonald's all those years
they're starting to melt from the
[ __ ] heat
oh yeah now you get good take your
finger like this get a fingernail and
scrape around your [ __ ] see that
green stuff that comes off those are
barnacles you have them cuz you're
eating garbage
you take that loaf when you scrub again
that's the second baby now you get a man
in that condition that's in you hey
you've worked it you shaved already it's
been there for four or five minutes bang
you do that long and then you
conditionally get hit with the [ __ ]
Irish Spring so you confuse people they
don't know where your loofah in it well
[ __ ] Irish bring it because the Irish
Spring stalls wears off and now the coca
is in there you following me you come
out you dry your feet you try your legs
you dry you dry your balls real good
because when they leave that moisture in
there that's that oh yeah dude yeah when
you take that bottle like you either I
love them you get that [ __ ]
you're almost smoke do you feel we're
getting the powder no I love it you're
taking you pop it in your ass when you
take a [ __ ] these are things you gotta
do as a human being to get the point be
you know washing your ass see your [ __ ]
how you gonna do anything you [ __ ]
argue with you gotta make time do you
get you get the baby
oh you mutt all your why would you have
a baby I mean every time I go to the
store I get the big powders and I get a
bunch of baby wipes I feel like a weirdo
but you gotta take three showers a day
nobody wants to hang around with stinky
people nobody why he always smelled like
he jumps just don't jump into a Greek
salad that's true godliness is next to
cleanliness
did you find dogs from me the last two
minutes of it yeah we can see would you
go
fast forward more more okay
it's back a little bit ten seconds
stop stop I love you [ __ ] the
church April 28th sometimes we run with
the national anthem and I go bananas
we're gonna end with the [ __ ] strong
dogs the last two minutes of dogs it's
tremendous they drop it on you you
understand me
who was brought in a house full of pain
who was taught not to spit in the fan
we're gonna drop on your [ __ ]
thank you for listening to the podcast
we have two live podcast Wednesday night
the Ice House 8 o'clock we have a
tremendous guest I don't know what is
yet yes and if not it's me myself and
[ __ ] my brother Lisa yet thank you
very much I want to thank my sponsors on
it shave club hulu hulu escape pod tank
comm I love you [ __ ] I love
Chung King I love everybody listens to
the podcast and thank you for love and
support you've given the podcasts over
the last yo but thank you very much stay
black and have a [ __ ] great day no
let nobody [ __ ] with you now the show is
over don't like Donald sterling to suck
your dick don't worry about it you got
it you got a job to do [ __ ] Donald's
family for your free trial food plus
Google Plus lets you Benjen thousands if
it shows any time anywhere on a TV PC
smartphone or tablet support this
podcasting in an extended free trial of
Hulu Plus when you go to Google Plus
outcomes Joey or go to Joey Diaz on that
and click on the Hulu Plus banner and
don't forget to sign up for Dollar Shave
Club Calm get high-quality razors sent
to your door every month for a fraction
of what you pay retail now go to
dollarshaveclub.com forward slash church
or go to Joey Diaz click on the Dollar
Shave Club